LAWMAKERS WORKING AROUND THE
CLOCK, THEY ARE BACK AT IT EARLY
TOMORROW.
BEAUTIFUL WEATHER ACROSS MUCH OF
THE COUNTRY TODAY DRAWING CROWDS
TO BEACHES AND PARKS AND BARS --
EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE BEING TOLD
NOT TO DO AT LEAST NOT WITHOUT
SOME SERIOUS SOCIAL DISTANCING.
>> IF WE CONTINUE WITH THAT
PROCESS, WE WILL FAIL AND
CONTINUE THIS VIRUS.
EVERY SINGLE GENERATION HAS A
ROLE TO PLAY.
WE ARE ASKING OUR OLDER
GENERATIONS TO STAY IN THEIR
HOMES.
WE ARE ASKING THE YOUNGER
GENERATION TO STOP GOING OUT IN
PUBLIC PLACES, THE BARS AND
RESTAURANTS, AND THE SPREADING
ASYMPTOMATIC VIRUS ONTO
COUNTERTOPS AND KNOBS AND
GROCERY STORES.
>> Shannon: DR. OZ JOINS US
NOW, I WANT TO READ A BIT IN
"WALL STREET JOURNAL," THEY HAD
A HEADLINE SAYING A GENERATIONAL
WAR IS BREWING OVER CORONAVIRUS.
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS ARE GROWING
CONCERNS OF THE MILLENNIAL
PUSHBACK AGAINST SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND AN EMERGING
GENERATIONAL DIVIDE ABOUT HOW
THE DISEASE IS PERCEIVED COULD
UNDO ALL EFFORTS TO SLOW THE
SPREAD OF THE PIRATES VIRUS -- W
YOUR MESSAGE TO PEOPLE WHO FEEL
YOUNG, FEEL HEALTHY AND THEY
FEEL COOPED UP?
>> THEIR GRANDPARENTS WENT TO
WAR, WE ARE ASKING THEM TO TAKE
IT EASY.
SIT ON THE COUCH, WASH YOUR
HANDS, TRY TO MAKE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT YOU ARE IN A
LITTLE SAFER.
I HAVE KIDS WHO ARE MILLENNIALS
AND EVEN AMONGST THEM WE WERE
HAVING A DISCUSSION -- THEY ALL
GET AT, THEY ARE SMART.
THEY UNDERSTAND THEY HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY -- THEY’VE GOT TO
HEAR THE MESSAGE STRAIGHT UP.
MANY OF THEM WERE CHASED OUT OF
COLLEGE THEY WEREN’T QUITE SURE
WHY COMMIT SEEMS ALARMIST, MUCH
OF THE COUNTRY FELT THAT TWO
WEEKS AGO.
WHEN YOU BEGIN TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENED IN ITALY AS A GOOD
EXAMPLE, YOU FEAR THE SAME MAY
HAPPEN HERE.
IT JUSTIFIABLY -- YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVEN’T SEEN THAT SAME NEWSFEED.
I FIND ONE MILLENNIALS GET IT,
THEY REALLY GET AT, THEY WANT TO
PLAY A ROLE AND THEY WANT TO DO
THE SAME THING GRANDPARENTS DID
BUT IT’S NOT TOO MUCH TO ASK.
IF YOU WANT TO GO TO A BEACH,
MAKE SURE YOU AREN’T WITH ANYONE
WHO IS AT RISK SOON AFTER.
IDEALLY YOU DON’T GO TO THE
BEACH, YOU DEAFLY DON’T GO TO A
BAR WITH THE WHOLE PURPOSE IS TO
BE NEAR OTHER PEOPLE.
>> Shannon: WE’VE SEEN US IN
FLORIDA.
SPRING BREAK GETS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN FLUXING
TO THE STATE, SOME OF THE
BEACHES ARE BEING MUCH TOUGHER,
CRACKING DOWN, KEEPING CROWDS
AWAY BUT OTHERS ARE NOT JUST
YET.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING FROM
ONE OF THE FOLKS WE CAUGHT UP
WITH ON CLEARWATER BEACH, HE
DOESN’T SEEM TO WORRY.
>> THIS A LOT MORE PEOPLE WHO
DIE FROM THE FLU COME A LOT MORE
PEOPLE DIE FROM SWINE FLU THEN
CORONAVIRUS WILL LEVEL EVER KILL
EVERYONE’S GOING TO GET IT
EVENTUALLY COMMITS A VIRAL
INFECTION.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT
TRANSMITTING IT TO ANYBODY?
>> NO, I PROBABLY GOING TO WIND
UP WITH IT JUST LIKE YOU WILL.
>> Shannon: FOLKS WANT TO BE
OUT AND HAVE A GOOD TIME BUT
SOME DON’T SEEM TO UNDERSTAND
THE THREAT.
>> 50% OF US WILL INDEED GET THE
VIRUS WE ESTIMATE OVER THE NEXT
YEAR BUT IF WE ALL GET IT AT
ONCE, THAT’S A CATASTROPHE.
THAT’S WHAT ITALY IS GOING
THROUGH NOW, THAT GENTLEMAN
UNFORTUNATELY IS TERRIBLY
MISTAKEN.
THIS VIRUS IS VERY CONTAGIOUS
AND IT HAS SHOWN ITS ABILITY TO
KILL AND ALTHOUGH THE INFLUENZA
SEASONAL FLU VIRUS CAN ALSO BE
DEADLY, OUR ESTIMATE IS THIS IS
SEVERAL TIMES MORE DANGEROUS,
HOW MUCH MORE DANGEROUS DEPENDS
A LOT ON HOW WE MANAGE OURSELVES
AND HOW WE ARE ABLE TO DEAL WITH
THE ISOLATION REQUIRED.
PLUS THERE’S A SOCIAL DISTANCING
THAT WE ARE PLEDGING.
YOU ARE ALREADY LOOKING AT
SUCCESS STORIES IN CHINA WHERE
THEY WERE ABLE TO CORRAL THIS
VIRUS IN ONE PROVINCE AND IT WAS
THE LARGEST QUARANTINE EVER IN
HUMAN HISTORY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE OTHER
PROVINCES, THEY DIDN’T GET THE
VIRUS NEARLY AS BAD.
SOUTH KOREA WHICH IS NOT
DISSIMILAR TO THIS COUNTRY’S
MEDICAL CARE HAS BEEN ABLE TO
REALLY SUFFOCATE THIS VIRUS,
THERE STARTED TO OPEN UP AGAIN.
IF WE DON’T HANDLE THIS RIGHT,
WE ARE NOT ONLY GOING TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THIS THE NEXT SIX,
EIGHT WEEKS, IT’S GOING TO
LINGER FOR A LONG TIME.
IF WE DO EVERYTHING CORRECTLY,
THAT GENTLEMAN WILL BE CLOSER TO
RIGHT BUT IF WE DO IT WRONG, I
WILL GUARANTEE YOU HE WILL BE
DEAD WRONG.
>> Shannon: YOU MENTIONED
ITALY, I WANT TO BRING THAT UP.
WE ARE HEARING ALL KINDS OF
REPORTS, THEY HAVE THE HEADLINE
ITALIANS OVER 80 WILL BE LEFT TO
DIE AS COUNTRY OVERWHELMED BY
CORONAVIRUS.
THE COURTED DOCTORS -- THIS IS
HOW IT IS IN A WAR.
IF THE TELEGRAPH SAYS THEY’VE
SEEN A DOCUMENT OUTLINING
PROTOCOL FOR HOW THEY MOVE
FORWARD, THAT’S GOT TO BE YOUR
WORST-CASE NIGHTMARE AS A
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONAL.
>> IT’S ARMAGEDDON IF THAT
HAPPENS AND WE ARE ALREADY
GETTING PRETTY FULL AND A LOT OF
HOSPITALS IN NEW YORK CITY.
YOU DON’T WANT TO PUSH THE
SYSTEM.
YES, WE CAN BUILD, ALMOST GET AN
ACCORDION ON ADDITIONAL HOSPITAL
BEDS, WE CAN PUT COSTS IN AND
HAVE PEOPLE COMMIT AND BUILD NEW
BUILDINGS BUT THE SMARTEST THING
TO DO IS TO GET PEOPLE TO LIMIT
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE PUT PRESENT
AT THE HOSPITAL.
IF WE DO THIS RIGHT, THE FIVER
STARTS TO DIE OUT.
IF WE CAN GET TO THE SUMMER
WHERE WE ALREADY HAVE A WEATHER
ADVANTAGE -- THE VIRUS PARTICLES
DON’T TRAVEL SO WELL WHEN THEY
ARE SWOLLEN.
WE WILL HAVE LOTS OF TIME TO
PICK UP SOLUTIONS FOR PEOPLE WHO
DO GET SICK.
WE WILL DO MORE TO KEEP THEM OUT
OF THE ICU AND KEEP THEM WITHOUT
A VENTILATOR.
WE NEED TIME.
IF WE BEHAVE LIKE NEANDERTHALS
AND DON’T RESPECT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THERE MIGHT BE
A CRISIS BECAUSE THIS HAPPENED
IN OTHER COUNTRIES, WE ARE GOING
TO GET BURNED AND WE ARE BETTER
THAN THAT.
AMERICA HAS ALWAYS BEEN ABLE TO
MAN UP AND MOBILIZE, THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US ONCE AGAIN TO
SHOW OURSELVES AND WE ARE BEING
ASKED TO SACRIFICE FOR PROBABLY
A COUPLE WEEKS AND AS
RESTRICTIONS COME OFF, MAY BE BY
JUNE, I ANTICIPATE WE GO BACK IN
THE WATER SO TO SPEAK.
>> Shannon: WE ALL CAN RISE TO
THE OCCASION AND HAVE CONFIDENCE
IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
THEY’RE GOING TO BE WILLING TO
SACRIFICE TO PROTECT EACH OTHER
AND THEMSELVES.